Hey, guys! A few hours ago, HBO  has released an official promo entitled "Long Walk" that features
Jon Snow,
Cersei Lannister, Daenerys Targaryen
and the blue-eyed white walker, who should be the night king since this teaser contains only the queens and the king.
This promo is way more interesting than any teaser that has been released since in this video
HBO provided the first official look at characters which accompanied with all those
magnificent realms makes this promo perfect. It starts with three main characters walking through the halls of their seats.
Jon Snow, walking through the halls of Winterfell with an outfit that extremely reminds me of Ned Stark. Daenerys
Targaryen walking through the halls of Dragonstone in an outfit that matches the colors of her house, and
Cersei Lannister walk through the halls of the Red Keep in the outfit similar to her season 6 finale outfit
After an, as title says itself, long walk through the halls, all three characters are entering their throne rooms, whereupon they continue walking
toward their thrones.  Cersei's walk  confirmed new look of the great hall aka
the throne room about which I'm going to talk about a bit more in a few moments.
After the long walk, Daenerys sits on the brand new throne that we are going to see at Dragonstone.
Cersei sits on the Iron Throne, and Jon Snow sits on the same place the last time saw him. As
they sit on their thrones, camera zooms in on their face, whereupon they shut their eyes, along with candles being extinguished.
Next scene is definitely my favorite as we can see by Cersei Lannister's breath winter has come far south all the way to the King's Landing
But for all of you who've been following my work here, this is not surprising as a few months ago
I brought you a few leaked photos in which we could see Jeremy Podeswa,
who is directing season 7 premiere and finale, shooting a few scenes in Dubrovnik, a beautiful city that will continue portraying parts of King's Landing.
However after shooting a few scenes for season 7 premiere with Lena Headey, known as Cersei,
and with Nikolaj
Coster-Waldau, known as Jamie,
Jeremy continued filming scenes without any actors on the shooting set, only snow machine which generates fake snow had been seen.
Beside a fact that Dubrovnik has always been portraying parts of King's Landing
and besides Lannister flags that have been seen hanging on the wall, Cersei's breath official confirmed that winter will come all the way to
the King's Landing.
Upon Cersei's breath which, is a clear sign of winter being present
through the most of the Seven Kingdoms at some point of the seventh season.
Video ends with an eye of the white Walker who in my opinion
should be the Night King as this video contains only the queens and the king.  As we can see in the upcoming season
they will have modified throne rooms and one totally new throne,
which is not surprising at all since several photos of both of those rooms were shared on social
media by a visitor to the indoor set at Titanic studios in Belfast. A few months ago
I brought you leaked photos of the modified throne room at Red Keep in which I said that exact modification is
replacement of seven pointed star adorning the window above the Iron Throne, which is going to be replaced by a lion.
But with this official video not only have they confirmed this but also revealed that the lion will adorn the side windows, which looks pretty
amazing.
Let's also say one or two sentences about the totally new throne at Dragonstone, which has also been leaked a few months ago
but it's now officially confirmed. Long story short, Daenerys will land in Dragonstone, on the east coast of Westeros, which is the ancestral seat of House Targaryen, and will sit on the new throne just as the queen deserves
And as always, let me know your opinion about all of this in the comment section down below
Hope you guys enjoyed this video if you did please make sure to subscribe to our channel
And I hope to see in the next one.  Peace!